hey guys it's Justine and today I'm
going to be making a fort night cake and
this is gonna be celebrating season 3
because season 4 is upon us or it's
actually already out depending upon when
you're watching this this is gonna be my
season 3 cake I'm really excited because
I just started playing this game and it
was one of those games that I really
avoided playing because I knew that it
was something that would take up all of
my free time so if you guys are
wondering Justine why haven't you been
posting YouTube videos that's because
I've been playing fortnight why don't I
stream fort night because I like to just
sit in my pajamas with Doritos on my
belly and be left alone and I like to
play my game and not have to talk to
anybody except my teammates sometimes
unless I'm playing solo then I'm just
dying a lot anyway I'm excited about the
cake but I'm also giving myself a time
constraint so basically while I'm
building the cake the storm is incoming
if I don't finish by the time the storm
gets to me I'm not really sure what's
gonna happen this is the first one I'm
making so stay tuned because your guess
is as good as mine currently while I'm
shooting this I don't have any
information on season 4 so depending
upon when you guys are watching you
probably already know everything about
it this is me this is me and lutely
swimmin ok shut up Jesse all right let's
make this frickin cake if you guys are
new here I am absolutely a terrible
Baker every once in a while probably
like 4 in 55 things that I've made
what's that percentage doesn't matter if
the storm is incoming starting now hey
these are our little meteors because at
the end of season 3 of the meteors we're
coming to destroy everything just as
stressful as the game when I'm going
running around trying to loot according
to our meteors first I probably should
make them a color but I'm not going to
because out on time and overtime for
that meteor number one when I'm baking
all I want to do is listen to music but
I can't because I'm shooting and you
guys can hear the audio but like maybe
let's just hear like one real quick
there's an entire container on these
meteors this is gonna be a problem
oh this is coming okay so these are all
the weapons that I have loaded we got to
get moving I have to make green icing I
have my green eyes because if I don't
have grass this is super creamy openes
cream cheese that would make sense I'm
gonna make this green gosh oh boy it's
happening you haven't even freaking
started icing let's go let's go we gotta
get this grass oh this is looking good
I'm trying it
what are you doing alright well that's
the thing that happened okay I sing in
the freakin storm is coming ah well
we've got two meteors
I haven't even built the fort yet I
haven't built anything how's this look
this looks like a nice little mountain
mists range let's go let's go let's go
there's one thing that I spend way too
much time doing its icing cakes when it
doesn't really matter especially when we
are supposed to be looting and looking
for weapons and Here I am icing a
freaking cake I'm actually probably the
last person you ever want to be anywhere
near your kitchen from no time guys
running out of time we're actually
cupcakes like I'm shooting this and
there's not even a real storm coming but
I'm freaking out
she's super unsteady just like my
emotions oh gosh lead steps queens and
stairs right here oh man we're running
out of time and I feel like I have not
accomplished anything I wanted to put
loot lake in have any blue yes yes yes I
do
blue like baby this looks like blue
turns this is disgusting this expired
because it smells like rotten I gotta
move all my items in because anything
that's outside the circle we're in
trouble
oh no guys you're so Wow oh no I will
protect all over Texas born in July oh
I'm trying so hard to catch it you think
I'm gonna stop building I'm not building
I'm not gonna stop I think we're all out
of meteors I guess what looks like I win
so I don't really know what else to do
in this video
except claim this as a victory let me
know if you guys would like me to make a
season 4 cake I'll try to make it before
the season is actually over I'm looking
forward to playing it and as I said
before at this current point of filming
this video I don't know anything about
season 4 yet because it has not been
announced it's not out yet most likely
when you're watching this it's already
been announced it's already out and
we're probably all playing it I will see
you guys there and if you see me hanging
out in the little fort come say hi I'll
see you guys later
I just cut down so many trees for this
like that there's cake everywhere what
do we do now
[Music]